I believe an interesting story is always
an interesting store
Beau Geste has
for it is that it's more than one thing
at once adventure film so war film it's
a mystery and it's an unusual kind of
love story instead of the regular
romantic boy-girl kind of love it's a
story about brotherly love three
brothers who would go through an
adventure together and their affection
and their bond when it first released it
was coming hard on the heels of the huge
success of the novel which came out of
19 24 and the audiences were really
ready for it they felt that it was
perfectly cast it was one of those kind
of Clark Gable gone with the wind things
when Ronald Colman seemed to be the only
possible actor on earth to play bow and
it was ecstatically received by
audiences got good reviews across the
board he did great box office everywhere
except in Europe because France bandit
for being anti French and then a lot of
other countries in Europe also banded
just to stay on Francis good side it was
it was a rough location as much as they
tried to make it as pleasant as possible
at a movie theater in a game tent and
hot and cold running showers from a hot
well that they found right under the
desert but it was still a rough location
and smallpox broke out during the
production and a lot of men had to be
quarantined against their will in many
cases it had to be kept secret or else
the Medical Board would shut him down
you